[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc en général quand on quand je
regarde mes images
la première chose qu'ils disent c'est
que je suis fou non donc fou ça fait
quand même référence à une santé mentale
un petit peu dégradée mais pour un
parent c'est le mot que les gens
utilisent pour décrire qui je suis et ce
que je fais avec ma planche ce que je
fais dans la vie
après cette folie personnellement je la
considère comme une chance elle m'a
apporté énormément de choses elle m'a
apporté le fait d'être différent et
d'une passion un chemin tout tracé
elle m'a apporté le fait de développer
ma propre vision du monde et de fixer un
petit peu moi même la méthode pour
atteindre mes rêves et mes objectifs
plus les années passent et plus je
réalise le genre de liberté que j'ai pu
acquérir en choisissant cette vie un
petit peu hors normes
cette vie d'homme fou entre l'hier même
après si je compare un petit peu à ma
vie et à notre vie un petit peu à tous
au quotidien au travail au téléphone aux
ordinateurs aux réseaux sociaux au
stress aux factures je me dis bon mais
la folie
est-ce qu'elle réside dans le fait de
sauter des barres rocheuses ce qui
réside dans le fait d'aller s'éclater en
montagne avec son snowboard de prendre
quelques risques
ou bien est-ce qu'elle réside dans le
fait de se faire un petit peu happé par
cette spirale du quotidien as qui nous
qui nous pompe toute notre énergie qui
les transforme en petit robot sans âme
je pense qu'on s'est tous de quoi on
parle
pour revenir un petit peu en arrière le
destin m'a mis entre les mains d'un
personnage haute en couleurs donc dans
les années 90 j'avais 13 ans à l'époque
et donc jean-michel le floch avait
décidé de nous apprendre le snowboard à
quelques amis mon frère et moi et donc à
l'époque on se doutait pas qu'on allait
apprendre bien plus que le fait de
glisser sur la neige en travers à
travers mes mais que jean-michel nous
transmettre tout un tas de valeurs qui
nous porte
enfin qui me porte encore aujourd'hui
énormément des valeurs comme comme le
fait de prendre la vie à bras le corps
de toujours voir plus loin de toujours
repousser les limites d'être passionné
et d'oser avoir des rêves donc la
manière dont il nous enseigne est un
petit peu tout ça à la manière du tyne
20 d'outils nous enseigner le snowboard
étaient tout sauf académiques
donc pour vous donner un petit exemple
donc pour nous apprendre à tourner donc
on n'était pas loin d'être débutant au
lieu de faire ça sur une piste tout plat
tout jamais comme la logique le voudrait
jean-michel nous amener sur le mur de
bosses le champ de bosses le plus raide
de la station nous apprenait à
karavellas dedans et je me rappelle
encore un petit peu de du visage et de
l'expression qu'il avait au sommet quand
ils nous regardent et qui le disait si
vous arrivez trop et là dedans vous
allez arriver à tourner n'importe où et
il se mettait à rigoler le coup suivant
il nous a emmenés faire des backflips
alors qu'on savait pas sauter c'est un
petit peu pour vous dire l'état d'esprit
dans lequel il était à quel point il
essayait toujours de nous faire
expérimenter de nous faire essayer des
choses nouvelles de nous faire toujours
tester nos limites
donc forcément on se prenait des
gamelles donc des gamelles en a pris à
tire larigot de temps en temps dans les
trois mêmes mal parfois mais mais au
final on savait qu'on était dans le
juste on savait que cela faisait partie
du truc
et quelque part ça nous allait très bien
et avec le recul je pense que une des
valeurs les plus importantes que jean
michel m'a transmise a été le fait de
d'apprivoiser cette peur qu'on a tous
fin cette peur que j'ai enfin si tu es
ma peur je parle pour moi mais je pense
qu'on est tous deux dans cette peur de
sortir de notre board de notes
zone de confort équipe cette peur qui
peut être un tel blocage et dans la
pratique du sport et dans la vie de tous
les jours donc clairement pour moi ces
quelques années auprès de jean-michel
ont été cruciales et on était vraiment
fonder la personne que je suis
aujourd'hui on fonder les bases de toute
ma carrière de tout ce que j'ai pu
réaliser jusqu'à aujourd'hui et je dois
énormément à cette personne donc
aujourd'hui 25 ans plus tard dans le
gène toujours braille des vides j'aime
toujours sauter des clichés aime sauter
j'aime retrouver je me retrouvais au
sommet d'une ligne soleil levant j'aime
aussi me retrouver dans des situations
où si j'agis pas correctement c'est que
les choses peuvent mal se passer
donc quand je dis mal se passer je fais
évidemment référence à la mort donc la
mort qui malgré tout présente il fait
partie intégrante de notre environnement
de la montagne et de la pratique du
freeride
c'est cette mort qui a toujours été pour
moi une bête noire et malgré un patient
qui a toujours été quelque chose de très
très difficile à gérer et affronter donc
dans la prochaine vidéo dans le prochain
extrait on va voir un petit peu un de
ces moments où les choses se sont très
très mal passé pour moi donc je vous
laisse juger par vous même
mieux vaudrait albina
hadas ans après
[Musique]
car les jeunes à cette oreille
ouais la coupe
[Musique]
donc c'est un mélange cette avalanche a
eu lieu pas très loin d'ici
donc c'était au-dessus d'orsières donc
sur une montagne qui s'appelle le
châtelet donc elle m'a tiré sur plus de
deux kilomètres et demi mes camarades
m'ont retrouvé posé sur 8 mètres de
neige donc le visage enfoui dans la
neige j'étais au bord de l'asphyxié au
bord de la mort
normalement ce genre d'avalanche on ans
survit pas et c'est clairement un
miracle que je sois là aujourd'hui pour
vous raconter cette histoire est donc
vous imaginez bien qu'après cet accident
après avoir frôlé la mort d'aussi proche
de si près j'ai enfin j'ai tout remis en
cause donc forcément ma première et ma
première réaction a été de vouloir tout
arrêter après le temps à petit la passe
et petit à petit donc les semaines les
mois et je sentais que j'avais toujours
en moi cette passion je sentais que
j'avais toujours cette étincelle
j'ai donc essayé de tout remettre à plat
tout réévaluer ma pratique
j'essaie de réfléchir sur la façon dont
je fonctionnais pour trouver une manière
de continuer à pratiquer ma passion tout
en ayant un niveau de risque acceptable
donc ma réflexion à ma portée sur le
fait de devenir complètement
intransigeant dans les manières de faire
dans mes manières de prendre mes
décisions en montagne de ne faire
absolument aucun compromis en termes de
sécurité
donc d'un côté je vous parle de folie je
vous parle de lâcher prise je vous parle
de casser les barrières de repousser les
limites et après d'un autre côté je vous
parle de manière froide mathématiques
cartésienne de fonctionner vous allez me
dire c'est deux choses qui sont
complètement paradoxale qui sont
incompatibles mais pour ma part je pense
que l' équilibre entre ces deux façons
de fonctionner diamétralement opposées a
été pour moi un petit peu la recette
magique qui m'a permis de réaliser ces
descentes est impossible et qui m'a
permis de repousser les limites de mon
sport donc aujourd'hui
j'ai une fille qui a 12 ans donc on me
pose souvent la question de me dire est
ce que ça a changé quelque chose pour
toi le fait d'être père dans ta manière
de gérer le risque
donc il faut savoir qu'au moment de sa
naissance avec sa mère on s'était posé
la question de savoir si on devait ou
non tout arrêter et donc il en est
ressorti que quelque part c'était un
petit peu la façon dont nous vivions
depuis toujours et que c'était ce qui
nous rend heureux et que malgré les
risques
le fait de lui transmettre toute cette
énergie toute cette passion nous
paraissait bien plus précieux que la
frustration engendrée par le fait de
renoncer à qui nous étions vraiment donc
depuis qu'elle est petite
j'essaie de transmettre à travers le
sport à travers la nature à travers la
vie de tous les jours toutes ces valeurs
que jean michel m'a transmis quand
j'étais plus jeune et 12 ans plus tard
je suis vraiment fier de voir
l'étincelle qu'elle a dans les yeux de
voir à quel point je peux faire
confiance et en montagne et dans la vie
de tous les jours et à travers elle je
réalise au combien cette folie est
quelque chose d'essentiel dans la vie et
ô combien c'est quelque chose
cette folie c'est quelque chose qui doit
être cultivée à tous les stades de la
vie dans l'enfance comme tous les jours
et aujourd'hui mon but c'est d'essayer
de rester fou aussi longtemps que
possible et d'encourager mes proches mes
amis ma famille est peut-être vous ce
soir à sortir de votre zone de confort à
prendre cette folie à bras le corps a
embrassé à bouffer la vie et parce que
je suis convaincu quelques parcs que le
fait d'être fou c'est le fait d'être
libre merci